leute bevor das video los geht erst mal
ein dickes dankeschön an ea die haben
dieses video nämlich überhaupt erst mal
möglich gemacht indem sie luca und mich
nach amerika eingeladen haben dort haben
wir unter anderem den fifa world cup
modus gespielt und durch den fifa 19
austesten
wenn ihr darüber mehr verantworten link
ist und in der beschreibung aber jetzt
erstmal viel spaß mit dem video
herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute ich bin hier gerade in einem
hotelzimmer und nicht irgendwo sondern
ich bin in los angeles california usa
juni eingeladen von ea später kommen
noch mal so ein kleiner clip der erklärt
weshalb überhaupt hier sind aber leute
ich war hier in einem amerikanischen
supermarkt und ich habe ganz ganz kranke
verrückte dinge gefunden die es nur in
amerika gibt und die möchte euch heute
vorstellen ich würde sagen wir fangen
wir relativ normal an wir haben ja
einmal gut rollups das von dingen ist es
uns aufgefallen es gibt ungefähr kein
obst in amerika also gibt es wird also
supermärkte die ein bisschen grüner sind
ja wirklich welche die erst wird es gibt
leute die haben einfach nur süßigkeiten
aber das würde uns auch so erzählt hier
die kids in amerika kriegen scheinbar so
was hier als obst so als für vitamine
und so deshalb machen wir es mal
aufregen die teile aus sind ganz viele
kleine davon drin ist so ein riegel
ich weiß nicht mehr da steht drauf flut
roll up also frucht ist anscheinend eine
frucht komm wir malen wie die
amerikanischen frischer aussehen also
das steht zumindest dass dort sieben
gramm zucker aber das steht auf 114
gramm
das sieht auch keine künstlichen
geschmeckt aber gucken wir uns mal
anders sieht einfach aus als sei da noch
mal irgendwie eine folie gewickelt alter
guck mal
man kann es komplett auf ihr kind alter
okay ich probier's mal irgendwie ist es
eigenartig es wie so ein ausgebautes mal
irgendwie gesund also tutti frutti mäßig
muss aber ein stecker okay leute bevor
es weitergeht mit der nächsten sache wir
sind ja hier von ea eingeladen das ist
so cool was wir machen können hier wäre
es gleich sehen wir waren beim creator
cup und haben für deutschland gespielt
ich will sagen dreht einfach nicht all
zu viel sondern guckt euch einfach an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja leute die highlights gesehen leider
haben wir nicht gewonnen aber es war so
cool also die ganzen leute
kennenzulernen fifa 19 haben wir auch
angetestet richtig fesch und ich würde
sagen weitergeht als nächstes haben wir
extra mit chocolate chip kaugummi
kaugummi mit schokoladengeschmack juni
von gehört ist roger tanner halten also
mit geschmack und kaugummi hotels durch
gang und gäbe aber schokoladen vertrag
brauche ich das krass jubelte button
tragen würde
geisteskrank ich hatte so einen kurzen
moment gehofft dass doch so spielen
stücke drin seite gewesen hat da wo wir
alter das ist voll krank dass er
schmeckt original wie sowieso einen
schokoladen mitteilt also dass der
testet gerade mannschaften schipek
zeichnet wenn du mein amerika seit
maximal klang oder ist er finde es sogar
richtig geil auf magazine der kurs
nächsten minsk kannst du dir gar nichts
wissen
die hat ja sogar schmerzen ist echt geil
irgendwie möglichkeit ist das auch so
über fieber bei uns ist ja ich glaube
kaum
weil wir uns extra doch sogar frisur ich
würde sagen bevor wir so mit den
klassikern weitermachen wo wir mal was
krasses rein
das pocket pc also ohne witz na gut das
ist ein bisschen eklig dass jetzt mit
den komischen aber eigentlich pizza
chips musst du probieren würde sagen ich
mach das mal auch nicht nur das ist halt
nur nach pizza ist nicht einfach so ganz
normal nach bringen ist wenn ich so
sehen die teile aus diesem teil kaputt
kommentar warum hast du kommen würde wo
wir unspektakulär ich hätte mir geiler
vorgestellt er recht ich würde sagen ich
würde sie probieren aber ich habe ganz
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt kein punkt also
probiere normalerweise so scheiße ist
ich finde aber alle sachen die irgendwie
so pizza flavour schmeckt mir nicht so
richtig geil also in sicherheit sind der
eigenen geschmack einfach halt brot mit
tomaten käse gegen diese aber alles was
danach macht es in diesen komisch was
mir aber irgendwie ein bisschen fehlt
das mit pizza ist das ist ein witz in
der krise fehlten irgendwie hätte ich
doch nur ich habe ohne witz im
supermarkt hier käse zum sprühen
gefunden
wie soll das funktionieren dass in
dieser dose käse zum sprühen ist käse
zum sprühen
let's go to you choose life wird direkt
vorgeschlagen probier's einfach fest
drücken
oh mein gott ich dachte das sei so ein
käse weißt du sowieso view in gelb so ca
diese woche vorgestellt eigentlich ist
folgerichtig
fragen wir doch die sache ist ich bin
ich gar nicht so ein riesiger käsefest
menschen die klatschen über alles
irgendwie noch einen käse schicht aber
das hier ist doch einfach nur pervers
krank ich probiere etwa das geht sehr in
die richtung von diesem nacho käse aber
ich mache jetzt den test mit einem pizza
2 max hat ja eine pizza chips die käse
variante diese funktion klein wenig pr
leute amerikanischer als das hier wird
es nicht mehr als käse auf einen pizza
chip.de skills in die komplette dröge
und musste nochmal deal or no deal
um mittel die und wird sich für skype
slightly ich finds geil ehrlich zu das
ist irgendwie sowieso ein heftiger
aktivierte er ist so so ja es ist sogar
ist das passt also geschmeckt schon auch
geil
das ist sowieso eine dritte sowieso ein
geiler käse tipps so zum abschuss halt
ungefähre alter das ist das geht aus der
flasche raus kannst du einfach dem bus
hier so und dann ist die verpackung
einfach lief also das war es interessant
auf jeden fall erstmal muss so sagen wir
vergleichen jetzt natürlich gerade
sachen dies in amerika gibt so etwas wie
flut roll ups oder pizza mit sachen die
in deutschland gibt die sache ist muss
erst mal die supermärkte vergleich zum
beispiel was ist an dem tag ist anders
als an einem normalen deutschen reiter
bei target wir waren ja gestern drin ist
so riesig und die sind in el also wir
sind irgendwie auf einem lang hier sind
ja die die mieten ja auch noch relativ
hoch das heißt ich glaube dass soweit
wenn man rausgeht oder eine vorstadt
desto größer werden die supermärkte
es gab alles es gab wirklich alles das
war so keine ahnung so in der stadt
einfach mitten in der stadt so markt wie
bei uns real oder globus oder so diese
gigantischen supermärkte
ich hab's mir gefeiert es gab so viele
verrückte so hatten
einerseits alles was du irgendwie von
haushalt brauchst irgendwie waschmittel
und aber auch lebensmittel und wasser
als dann auf der anderen seite hatten ja
auch rasenmäher und spielekonsolen und
klamotten so alles man kann sich
eigentlich vorstellen wie so ein
großhandel großen bei uns kann man ja
auch vollkommen in der metro oder so sah
die amazonas supermarkt ja als nächstes
ein amerikanischer klassiker pop-charts
das sind eigentlich ich glaube die alten
postplatz weil man die so im toaster
rein tut man poppen diese hoch und chaos
wegen partien so zu sein
man kann ja aber auch so essen und wir
haben sie in der geschmacksrichtung
small geholt es klappt irgendwie
marshmallow mit irgendwas anderen post
sms chat typischen liegt david wo mein
gott walter sieht das nach zucker aus
aber so richtige zuckerglasur darauf
alter ist sie auch sein fett weg sondern
eine schokolade daraufhin gleich zweiter
das land wird also sieht schon mögliche
aus wie dafür oder wenn ich mir ganz gut
an meinen händen meinte ich jetzt nicht
nach denn so ein bisschen nach pickup ja
stimmt also dass franck auch viel geiler
aus aber vielleicht muss einfach mal
reinbeißen und den kompletten text
olaf deception mail.ru im rücken kann
man denn hier grading so hinweis mehr
willst du dir ein bisschen mehr als so
ein neutrales dinge ist das schmeckt wie
so baby keks und einen text du diese
dieser baby kekse nähe wo dieses
frühstücks kekse vereinigen sich nicht
sondern ich war immer schon bis zum jahr
des flash jetzt haben wir es also so wie
es jetzt geradeaus von innen sieht auf
jeden fall schon mehr aus wie auf der
verpackung aber von oben also da steht
einfach lässt sich aus dem bild gut dass
sie gleich probiert jetzt nochmal
wurdest du an dem zeug angelangt bin
das bin ich von so bis zu so gegangen
ist einfach immer mehr essen dann bist
du als kind würde ich glaube ich
übertrieben abfeiern aber so muss man
jedes süßigkeit ab aber ich frage mich
wie das gegessen wird wird es so stark
dass man sich irgendwie brot schmiert
morgens haben dieses einfach ein toaster
und dann essen wir das wahrscheinlich da
haben wir auch erfahren dass die
amerikaner wirklich halt denken kannst
du dich soll jetzt hier mit dem widmen
was so ja genau das das festival
products gesagt und zwar wir haben hier
eine mitarbeiterin von studio 1 70 von
unserem netzwerk getroffen und dann
erzählt sie war bei einer gastfamilie
und in dieser gastfamilie wurde den
kindern abends immer solche flut zum
beispiel gegeben und dann haben sie
gesagt die kids will jetzt der beide
minister also sie kriegen jetzt ihre
vitamine dann haben die den einfach mit
zucker überzogenen gummibärchen gegeben
die halten und das ist gut drauf da sind
wir schon vitamine drin also wer sein
dass ich bisschen verrückt kommen wir
zur letzten sache ich habe mir das auch
privat für euch ist es so verrückt wir
haben hier aber keine normalen sondern
firework kurios die innen drehen popping
candy haben also da kommt schon krank
also ja leute torrijos bei denen die
creme zu knistern noch infobox geführt
ist das ding ist in der ios sind doch so
die sind ja nicht wirklich schokolade
schmecken so ein bisschen schokolade
oder ich finde oreo kekse schokolade ja
trotzdem war ich meine was zur hölle
haben ist dieses kapitel zu probieren
ich das ndr medienmagazin zapp gerät
alter schwede was sind da drin
leute ich probiere den spaß krass ist
schmeckt genau die orders aber das bitte
einfach so eigenartig können jetzt mal
nur die creme heraus also was soll ich
dazu sagen es schmeckt genauso euro ist
aber dass größere das war's minister
noch aus seinem mund es schmeckt genau
wie all dies aber ist nichts halt im
mund ich weiß nicht ob ich das gut
finden oder nicht bin sehr
unentschlossen darüber aber allein dass
das gibt es einfach so bescheuerten das
ist glaube ich sehr amerikanisch ja
leute ich würde sagen das war's von
unserem heutigen test video ich überlege
noch ganz kurz war zwar nicht am
geilsten das geilste was mir am besten
gefallen hat waren tatsächlich die
tauben mies weil ohne witz das ist
einfach so heftig kaugummis die nach
schokolade schmecken hätte nicht gedacht
das ist so geil ist auf jeden fall
vielen lieben dank noch mal an ea dass
das ganze überhaupt möglich war für uns
mein erstes mal in amerika ich habe es
unfassbar gefeiert das event habt ihr
gesehen war auch mega cool und ja dann
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder schaut auch bei
luca vorbei ist und verlinkt und dann
sehen wir uns